i'm no expert in love
the emotions it brings the internal
turmoil you might feel i'm
versed in none of it and in this sense
it's easy to connect to violet
evergarden the titular character of her
series violet finds herself with no
purpose
no knowledge of the social world or its
inner workings nor
how the most simple social interactions
should work and in this way again
many introverted souls and people with
feelings of isolation
can find their place in her character
but the one thing violet does have and
can hold onto from the start of her
story in violet evergarden
is a single phrase
in japanese or simply i love you
more so than the more casual ski this is
a true profession of love in japanese
a language and culture that avoids
direct confrontation at just about all
costs
so it's kind of a big deal these are the
words given to her by her former general
and superior in the military she fought
for during the big war
in the violet evergarden verse but after
the supposed death of said general in
battle and the loss of her two arms
violet is left lost as i'm sure many
veterans feel like after years of
devotion to war
the foundation of violet evergarden
works so well from the start because we
begin in the aftermath of war and of
constant battle
what is universally recognized as a time
for reformation
and new beginnings it throws us onto a
blank slate
with nothing but violet and the single
phrase she wishes to know the meaning of
what she ends up actually making into
her life's purpose
to find what it means and the beauty
or perhaps irony of violet's journey in
this anime
is that she has absolutely no idea what
i love you means
us watchers even if we've personally
never been in love before
can still grasp the concept through
perhaps our parents or movies we watch
or
anime of course but because of the way
viola was raised she is blissfully
ignorant
in a way that opens her mind to anything
and everything that can provide insight
into what it means
and naturally this leads her to become
an auto memory doll
arguably the only job in the violet
evergarden verse where you really have
to understand someone's emotions to do
it properly
which of course violet does not
in a world where very few can write but
all can read
if someone wishes to send a letter or
communicate with a loved one from afar
an auto memory doll must translate their
words for them onto the paper
despite the job's rather misleading name
dolls are
real people though but it also works as
a rather on the nose testament to the
initial simplicity of violet's character
and how she is essentially just an
emotionless doll
but as she improves at her job and by
extent at
understanding people's emotions violet
evergarden teaches us through the
various lives of people who wish to
write letters
the innumerable ways that the words i
love you can take shape
what it means to translate one's inner
emotions and truly express it to someone
else
and the journey of finding purpose in a
time when all you can feel is lost
violet evergarden reaches out to the
lost sheep of the world
and shows them a tale of retribution and
humanity
and that's why i love it
[Music]
though the largest theme permeating
throughout the show is the meaning
of love and finding what it is it
wouldn't do the show justice to just
keep it boxed within something like the
romance genre
as it is also political and slice of
life and fantasy
and because of this it's hard to
pinpoint also what makes the show stand
out among the rest
because violet evergarden is reputable
for reasons other than its god tier
animation
what it excels at is its display of
ambiguity
violet's job itself is incredibly
ambiguous
she has to take whatever someone says be
it long-winded gibberish or
posh words of a princess and turn it
into a letter that makes these emotions
known
violet is the essential middleman or
middle woman who sits through all this
content
and instead of taking bits and pieces
from what someone says
reforms it entirely to express the
feelings of love
how the letter turns out really all
depends on violet's interpretation
the sender themselves doesn't really
know how to say i love you
and the fact that violet must continue
to translate letters every day
shows that there is no one specific way
to say it
if there were after all her job wouldn't
exist
the idea of love encompasses so many
things
but if violet evergarden were to define
it
what would it be
to be completely honest i'm not sure
again
as someone who is rather not well versed
in this area
to put it lightly i'm probably not the
right person to be cracking down on this
but in a way violet is even worse off to
this than i
am and of course yes she is fictional it
really wouldn't make sense to compare my
struggles directly to hers
but that is exactly the point of these
videos to find what is human
in art to see the inner emotion
underneath the surface of animation
and what i've discovered in violet
evergarden and analyzing it
is that i don't think anyone here really
knows what love is either
something violet evergarden makes
extremely clear thematically is the pain
of separation the setting itself in a
post-war period
is perfectly suited for this having a
loved one fight in a war
far away and even once it finishes
there's a chance they might not return
should things go wrong the idea of auto
memory dolls as an occupation
also reinforces this as the job is
inherently only necessary for those who
wish to reach out to loved ones who live
far away the violet evergarden verse is
filled with people who miss
their loved ones violet's day to day as
she tries to find the meaning of love
means encountering these people
constantly having the emotions of
separated lovers unloaded onto her that
she can write it out
and the irony is that she is also one of
these separated people
she's writing for people who are in the
same position as her
and so maybe if we look at it from a
broader sense perhaps love is simply a
bond so
strong that no one can destroy it be it
physical or the more abstract distance
to the afterlife
maybe it's that bond that urges people
to continue making letters
but if violet doesn't really know what
love is if she is a victim of this
painful separation herself
why do her letters work how can someone
who questions what love is themself
expressed someone else's emotions let's
dig a little deeper
what if love is the words themselves
violet's entire journey to understand
the phrase's purpose
begins with those simple words of i love
you
her job as a doll is to translate
emotions into words onto a letter that
can be sent to someone
a job that is so essential that royalty
hires her
mayors of cities get her to recite
speeches
perhaps what is most important is not
the emotion itself
but the words in which it is expressed
but you can continue to debate this and
what the show does
is establish a perfect balance between
these two aspects
the emotion and the expression
on one hand we have such cases as the
girl who has sent a letter on every one
of her birthdays from her mother who
passed away years ago
in this situation the words themselves
clearly carry the weight
they sustain the emotions of the
long-lost mother and make it known
every year but in violet's case for
example her love with the general is
suspended from a single phrase
the words i love you themselves don't
really hold much power
compared to the time they spent together
the emotions she feels towards him and
the hope that he still lives
and thus through violet's tale of
writing letters and her own story
the idea of love is expressed in so many
ways be it through emotions or words
ultimately once again contributing to
that idea of ambiguity she
is unsure herself of how she feels
the people who she writes letters for
can't concisely put it all into words
either violet has to translate for them
so do any of these people know what
love's meaning is
violet evergarden is ultimately a story
of recovery
mending the wounds of war the pain of
separation
and how close this time can bring people
in a period that is stricken with
sadness for those who have passed
but thankfulness for those who didn't
regret for those you left behind
and hopefulness to a brighter future
with the ones who stuck around
they all tie together to this idea of
love for one another
to this phrase of i love you violet
evergarden never defines what love is
but makes sure by the end of the story
what began as just violet
on a white template is now filled with
memories and emotions that ultimately
define that phrase for her
because that's what it is love isn't
something that you can express
but once you have it you know
that obscurity is violet evergarden's
meaning of love
it doesn't matter if the people who want
to send letters can't write it
themselves
or if violet can't express their
emotions properly
or if the recipient doesn't understand
it fully
because it isn't something so simple
that it can be encaptured in just
words or in just emotion which seems
rather counter-intuitive now that i say
but yes to resolve this long-winded
section on the meaning of love in violet
evergarden
i have arrived at the answer that you
just feel it out and
you'll know i hope you guys enjoyed the
video i took a much more broad and
open-ended take on the idea but
nonetheless
if you took something away from it
that's all that matters to me
as always this has been the anime
culture corner i hope you enjoyed the
video
don't forget to like and subscribe for
future end up show manga and character
[Music]
analyses
you